you had early success in your
screenwriting career as you had your
first screenplay option for like a few
thousand dollars I think in the
beginning and then you wrote for six
years and you were able to sell recount
to HBO
so most people would have given up in
that six year period especially now when
everybody wants everything like that
why didn't you that's a great question I
mean the early success wasn't really
success I would say I wouldn't really
call it early success I it was I don't
even view it that way I view it as six
years of no one wanting my stuff and it
was you know some random person who was
very kind was interested in a script but
it wasn't as if it was all of a sudden I
made it and I it's happening now so it
really was a six seven year journey to
selling my first project which was
recount and why I didn't give up I think
is because I had something to say and I
loved writing these scripts and they
were important to me and I loved working
on stories and it just was artistically
extremely fulfilling where my acting
career was very frustrating and
sometimes I and I worked I did really
some worked on some terrific shows that
I'm really proud of but I wasn't
actually getting to act very much so
even when you're working you know I
would do episodes of Gilmore Girls and I
would do four episodes of season and I
would work on it a day or two and that
would be one of my only jobs for six
months so it's really about seven days
on set over a six month period so what
am i doing the rest of the time I'm
auditioning and trying to get new jobs
but that's an hour a day maybe so really
it was it was a creative outlet for me
of taking my creative energy and putting
it into something where I can actually
just go do it where as an actor you have
to be picked to go do it and then you
rarely get picked so I just found it
fulfilling but I also was getting
rejected and left and right script after
script and agents managers production
company everyone didn't want my work for
six seven years and I think I got to a
point where I asked myself
this is not going well what are you what
do you want from this what what are you
doing and I sort of I asked myself would
I and it's one of the key questions in
the movie would I do this for the rest
of my life if I got nothing in return
and I thought yeah I would and then I
just kept writing and then eventually it
wasn't as if six months later cracked
the champagne it was maybe three years
later that I sold recount it's a pitch
to HBO and then just kind of went on
from there but there was a certain peace
in knowing that it wasn't about it
wasn't about selling something or
success even though I really wanted it I
wasn't at what you know wasn't a kumbaya
moment but there was a peace in knowing
that well whatever happens you just keep
writing so just keep writing and that's
what I did yeah and I saw that you would
that I think did two parts of the movie
that that premise yeah which I think is
a big eye-opener to a lot of people
that's something that most people may
not be ready for yeah and look at what
JD Salinger did right he stopped
publishing at the height of his fame and
then continued writing for 45 years for
nothing in return and he wrote every day
and he just did it because he just
wanted to write and I think to me that's
what makes this story a profound story
is the journey of the artist and he goes
from being a young man who all he wants
his success to being an older writer
which all he wants is to just create his
art and nothing else and that's that's
the journey that's the the Aesop fable
of this movie
you